-Music from Paramore
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.
-[ Singing funk indistinctly ]
-♪ That's how you do it ♪
-♪ That's how you
do it ♪
-♪ That's how ♪
-♪ How you do it ♪
♪ And then we're going
to do it ♪
-♪ Ay ♪
-♪ Tell me where we're gonna ♪
♪ Do it at right now ♪
-♪ We'll start right here ♪
-♪ Start right there ♪
-♪ And, by here, we're
gonna do it ♪
-♪ Then go right there ♪
-♪ But what if we decide
to do it? ♪
-♪ No ♪
♪ You start not doing it,
then you do it ♪
-♪ Somebody did it ♪
♪ Yesterday ♪
-♪ I'm gonna pretend like
I'm not gonna do it ♪
-♪ And I'm gonna walk
over here ♪
♪ And just stare
at this brother ♪
-♪ What are you gonna do ♪
♪ While I'm here not doing it? ♪
-♪ I don't think we've
discussed enough ♪
♪ How we're gonna do it ♪
-♪ But, once I get
from here to there ♪
♪ We're all gonna do it ♪
-♪ Somebody better do it ♪
♪ Or else, it won't get done,
yow ♪
-♪ I said, one, two ♪
♪ One, two, three, here we go ♪
♪ Now, we're gonna do it ♪
-♪ One two, whoo! ♪
-♪ Now, we're gonna do it ♪
-♪ One, two, three ♪
♪ Now, we're gonna do it ♪
♪ Now, we're gonna
do it ♪
-♪ And it's, and it's ♪
♪ What is it? ♪
♪ What is the thing ♪
-♪ That we were gonna do? ♪
-♪ Remember we discussed it? ♪
-♪ I remember what it was ♪
♪ I remember what it was ♪
-♪ Thank God, thank God ♪
-♪ We're gonna start here ♪
♪ Come on, let's start
over here ♪
-Okay.
-♪ And now we're going back ♪
♪ To the front ♪
-♪ Go back to the front ♪
♪ Get low, low, get low,
get low ♪
-♪ Ah, ah, ha, ha ♪
♪ Ha, ha, ha, ha ♪
-♪ Get low, get low,
get low, get low ♪
♪ Say ha, ha, ha, ha ♪
♪ Ha, ha, ha, ha ♪
-♪ Ha ♪
-Whoo!
-We did it! We did it!
We did it!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]